quand j'étais petit le monde grouillait
de dragon rares sont ceux qui savent où
ils sont allés notre histoire a changé
le monde à jamais on a réussi un monde
idéal où vivent en harmonie dragon
speaking bonbons d'idéal mon lit des
halles à moi j'en mange on comprit plus
j j a ni des moments où tu là il est
donc pas me désole et vient de se
volatiliser
ah ah
un monde caché de dragon
oh
vous représentez
[Musique]
une petite copine j'ai chassé tous les
furie nocturne excepté le tien livres le
mois
jamais je ne me livrerai dans ce cas je
détruirai tout ce que tu tiens
on est plus en sécurité ici on doit tous
se cacher disparaître
nous devons nous battre pour leur
liberté
[Applaudissements]
santon dragon tu n'es rien
montrent leur ce que tu as dans le
centre
[Musique]
sauf le
toi et moi mon grand pour toujours
[Musique]
2000 va pas qu'est ce qui t'a alim
attachez votre ceinture en dresser votre
siège rangez votre tablette
parce que nous allons pas tardé avec
ralph te plaît pour une fois est ce que
tu peux plus clair on va dans l'internet
cure
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue
cool
regarde moi tous ces machins nouveau
miracle que j'ai jamais vu de toute ma
vie
bienvenue au bar de recherche que
puis-je vous aide à trouver aujourd'hui
bain moussant pains de minuit bain de
foule au nom de ville noms de pays non
date est à la sic
arbalète artichauts j'ai comme
l'impression qu'il essaie de deviner ce
que tu as à dire m'a saisie automatique
est un peu nerveuse ces jours ci attend
laisse trouvez moi un site internet qui
déchire bien des livres
oh je n'ai qu'un seul résultat non
dispensés du personnage de dessin animé
[Musique]
tu vas me fuir
salies on se calme ici je suis une
princesse mozy et quel genre de
princesses et tu ta chevelure est
magique non humains sont magiques
non tu parti avec les animaux non
contentes oiseaux les noms ensorcelé non
enlevées séquestrées nord vous êtes sûr
que ça va ou faut que j'appelle la
police
est ce que les gens pensent que tous les
problèmes se sont réglés parce qu'un
homme fort et puissant a surgi dans ta
vie oui mais comment ça se fait
d'ailleurs c'est une vraie princesse
[Musique]
une éternité s'est écoulé depuis les
effroyables événements du mardi des
tacos
nos vies ont sombré dans le chaos cette
nouvelle vie nous a tous aguerris et du
aussi d'un café s'il vous plaît un noir
et un avec un léger soupçon de l'est et
25 ans enfin presque tous
un effort
bonjour merci
voilà moi bonjour les bd et coût et met
il faut que tu arrêtes de faire comme si
tout était super génial c'est pas le cas
oui je sais c'est pour ça que je me suis
forgé un côté hyper dur et insensible
regarde une étoile filante fait un peu
oui
[Musique]
un nouveau truc
qu'est-ce qui la brique
j'en sais rien et ce sont les super
branché
[Musique]
belhaj c'est comme s'il savait où on va
ouais c'est dingue et met toi et moi
votre chef le plus redoutable huila
c'est le spécial two table ça en réalité
les combats c'était moi mais donc tu
t'es battu et tu as construit et tu as
tout déchirer et c'est le mag minable
qui était le chef il
accroche-toi des feuilles planty on est
parti pour sauver lucie et tous les
autres qui ont été capturés
[Musique]
voyez le système systar
le web donnez pas la satisfaction de
vous entendre dire wang demain ça c'est
encore pire ne des plus rien
[Applaudissements]
que puis-je faire pour vous seigneur des
ténèbres
je cherche le grand amour vous cherchez
une grande armure non non ce que je veux
c'est l'amour d'une femme vous voulez le
mur d'une ferme
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit je veux
faire humour aux comptes
je veux de l'amour je comprends je
voulais des rames en alliant trop pas
assez d'yeux je n'aime pas les
tentacules papa tu es stressé à force de
trop travailler tu dois prendre des
vacances ne plus occuper des vacances
des autres et je sais comment arranger
ça m'évite s'il te plaît du mois où nous
allons troisière oui oh non non non non
non non non non pas aller il ya mille
choses à faire tu peux faire de la
plongée déguster des mets délicats ou
juste profiter de la vue
génial papa merci beaucoup
quelqu'un pourrait allumer un feu
d'artifice dans ton coeur ti ce n'est
pas la croisière s'amuse franck salut la
compagnie je présente
vous devez être légendaire comte dracula
adouli bout la googlisation mines eu
quelques mots suffisent à un homme pour
briller aux yeux d'une femme par son
intelligence
adoli blague ou lydia sion mines est
assurée chéri passe des vacances d'où tu
avais raison grand père valentim les
monstres sont écoeurants il ne se doute
pas de ce qui va leur arriver
tout se déroule comme prévu
[Musique]
quelque chose chez cette femme de masse
pire tu as confiance ce plat est mort
tellement délicieux quatre amis de l'aïe
dans le guacamole ce n'est pas un poison
pour vous
[Musique]
c'était vous
oh non bluebeam à vomir
[Musique]
elloumi d'etion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
méchant monsieur green vous êtes un très
bon dit aussi qu'un qu'attendu sous qui
me libère et reçus
oh c'est un fait éclore une banane
pourrie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous allons faire des choses
méchantes et nous allons les faire de
façon stylet bonjour c'est quoi ça est
ce que vous les produits non
[Musique]
où
je ne connaissais la jungle que par
terre et si je vivais dans le bonnet
d'un roi dans une cage comme celle ci je
mords des jeux griffer et je passais mon
temps à me battre et puis un jour j'ai
arrêté et j'ai gagné leur confiance
gagner leur confiance petit frère
[Musique]
tu n'es plus en sécurité dans l'agenda
il faut que tu restes au village tout
ira bien
petit frère
quand je t'ai trouvée
il ya tant de saisons déjà j'ai cru que
je pourrais apprendre à trouver sa place
mais je me trompais manquer ça par
exemple c'est fou ce que tu as grandi
[Musique]
non
quand tu étais petit il n'y avait pas de
peur dans tes yeux j'étais sûr qu'un
jour qui apporterait la paix dans la
jungle
mais tu es devenu un homme maintenant
mowgli
je ne suis pas un homme
je ne suis pas non plus en une fois
[Musique]
je crois que nous serons tous les deux
d'accord pour dire que tu es d'une
espèce que la jungle n'a encore jamais
connu